So Pete,
what kind of design principles or
design thinking goes into
the product of Optimizely?
>> Sure.
So two things come to mind that I think
has served us well from the beginning.
When we started Optimizely,
to see our competitor's products,
you had to go through a multi-step sale
cycle, which was really frustrating.
And so, we had no name.
We had no reputation,
we had no sales people either.
And so we built our product in such
a way that anybody could go to
Optimizely.com and enter their website,
and immediately get the feeling for
what it was like to use our product.
And I like think of that as putting
our product where our mouth is.
You know?
And that forced us to design something
that was easy enough to use that
anybody could get it.
Because the product was
the sales person, initially.
And the second one I think that really,
really served us well was this idea of
enabling the novice, but
empowering the expert.
And that comes through.
When you look at our product,
we built a visual editor.
So, whether you're
looking at a website or
a mobile application,
you can use your mouse.
You can drag things around.
You can change text.
You can do a lot of simple
things without having to
understand code at all.
But we're engineers,
and we were never really all that
trustful of wizzy wig editors like that.
We don't typically use
Microsoft Word for that reason.
And so, to satisfy our own itch there,
we also made it possible for anybody
to go under the hood and see exactly
the code that we were generating as
a result of all this visual stuff.
And that made it possible for
a marketer to go in and use it, but
also their web developer to go in and
see exactly what was going on.
We found that that's one of our
most consistently used features,
to our surprise.